nothing's not good enough for you ever
go find some other
I don't deserve it to me okay
[Applause]
these two need to go ahead and call it
quits this is what it looks like when
it's not working Nicole and Mahmoud get
into another intense fight this time the
altercation is in public in the streets
of Egypt and you know what the social
rules of Egyptian culture seeing
something like this is rare look at the
people in the back staring I just want
you to leave me alone okay go alone I
will okay go
wait did he just buck at her
what is this the Wild Wild West
[Music]
they look like enemies we'll get into
what led up to Nicole in my mood's
argument this time around and what an
extremely embarrassed my mood is
threatening to do next I will wait till
5 minutes
I don't give up whatever you want to do
just go
let's talk about it
hey 90 day fans fam it's Malicia before
we get into Nicole in my mood I want to
give you an update on Debbie and Usama
or as she likes to call him Osama I'll
launcher text this
I still got a lot to think about Osama
quick refresh last episode
hurt Miss Debbie's feelings and shocked
us told her on the derived in Morocco
that he wants her to go back to the
states in a month or two when she
thought she was moving to Morocco
indefinitely I didn't come over here to
be disrespected like that I know that's
right this week's episode picks back up
on them the next morning and Usama is
apologizing saying his words literally
got Lost in Translation last night it
was a Mis misunderstood in the
translations and you know we put like a
plan in general but we didn't focus on
the detail that's not a very good excuse
well at least in this case it isn't I
think Osama forgot what he admitted to
last night well I need to live with you
on a reality to see if you accept me in
reality if me accept you in reality why
couldn't you tell me gee Debbie why
don't you come and I'll see if I can
accept you in reality or not why didn't
you say something like that
because if I say to you this they went
but
you know that I want to marry you right
I guess
it's true it will happen
last night you said
you said that
the drama Department's summer program
oh I'm just Sage it's okay
had you told me that and you said well
that's why I didn't tell you and it's
like you took something away from me
yesterday and you know I need to feel
trusted again I know okay yeah and I'm
sorry for last night because I don't you
mean last night and you know me very
well I
understanding
and you can prove that you love me yep
that's all I love you in real life he's
being so apologetic and and you know me
it's like I'm thinking okay you know let
me cut him some slack maybe it was
miscommunication
she goes on to say that she didn't come
this far to give up but she also admits
it's hard to rebuild trust and she isn't
sure if they can do that fast forward
after all the drama settles Usama takes
Miss Debbie on a beach day and she has
the time of her life oh my gosh hey hey
no underwear
are you nice boy because of the camel I
love you camel
do they got a seat belt
actually
I'm not mad at that question do they got
a seat belt what a seat belt together
Osama said I'll be a seat belt please
[Music]
Debbie sounds like cats who are mating
have you ever heard the sound of cats
mating
it is disturbing I know this is random
but if you know
you know
[Music]
that Camel is probably like what is
going on on my back
[Music]
don't worry be going nowhere oh my gosh
look at it
[Music]
I mean I feel very very funny and very
happy because she just let the inner
girl inside of her just I mean get alive
again
[Music]
that's that Sugar Hill Georgia coming
out of Miss Debbie
because she is crazy but this is the
reason why I make me love her because
I'm crazy too
oh
she makes me want to ride a camel after
they finish Debbie asked Usama if he's
embarrassed by her and he said something
really sweet he's good with his words
when he wants to be when I am with you I
don't care about what's around me
because I don't see anything that I'm
angry
so you I didn't embarrass you because no
no no you don't I I don't trust me those
because I want to see you happy because
I would never never want you to be
ashamed of me you always forget my rules
because I told you when I see you
nothing around me is exits because I see
only you because yes I thought well I
get sick or something happened to me I
travel around I will sign family and you
not those people this is why I don't
care about the Judgment of the people
that's real why would you allow people
who you aren't even close to to make you
feel ashamed of someone who is always
there for you thank you for for being
strong like that thank you is love this
is love all right enough of those two
for now let's move on to Nicole and my
mood who can't seem to get it together
when it comes to compromising on their
cultural and religious differences last
night when we got back from mahmoud's
uncle's house we agreed to just stop
talking about our problems for now
because we're exhausted quick refresh
this episode picks up the day after
Nicole threatened to leave him by
packing her bags they were both upset
because they couldn't find common ground
on how Nicole should dress as mahmoud's
wife but as she said for now they are
letting it go maybe the answer to this
crisis is prayer
their day starts off nice Mahmoud was
teaching Nicole how to pray the Islamic
way which is something he's been wanting
her to do more often
I mean he starts um like saying the the
prayer into the most beautiful voice and
I've never heard it before and I it was
just moments like
these that just remind me how much I
love him and he's always so full of
surprises
I think it's beautiful to be that
devoted to something I actually feel
really close to him in this moment well
I hope she enjoyed it while it lasted
fast forward these two decide to go to
the pool because it's a hot day but
wearing a burkini gives Nicole a lot of
anxiety one of my favorite things is
swimming I really like to be near the
water and in the water it's really been
an issue because of the swimsuit that
Mahmoud makes me wear
you know you're the only person that
would do this for I know honey I'm ready
to do anything for you okay do you have
to wear I mean this is a weird question
you have to wear something under it
do you I'm gonna need him to stop
rolling his eyes like that she asks a
legit question what I don't know you
don't know no well I need to know I
don't know girl don't follow him let him
have his attitude
you seem to be kind of mad no I'm not
mad yes he is he is stressed he went and
got a cigarette and everything go gets
hot okay
I told you they put honey sweetheart oh
my love at the end of all these
sentences where they're slick snapping
at each other I don't get my mood's
behavior right now how is Nicole
supposed to know these things if you're
gonna get frustrated during a teachable
moment why did you marry someone so
different from you honestly y'all are
going to be learning from each other for
the rest of your life well
that's if this works out
I'm so tired of him always getting so
mad at me and it's like he he really
resents me for being American I think
once I get to the pool Nicole opens up
about how swimming was once something
that made her feel free now it reminds
her of how much she's not being herself
not long after I married him why
wouldn't I we're at the red seat and
there were a lot of tourists wearing
bikini or that's just like a one-piece
suit whatever just normal
I remember feeling
jealous like that was how I used to be
and then I've been like kind of taken
from that life and then
this is my new life and I'm just not
used to and I don't like it that much
you know I don't like I don't like to
wear that well it's the life you chose
Nicole but it's also not too late to
choose you Nicole goes in the ladies
room to change into her swimwear and
next thing we see is Nicole looking
pitiful in her bikini I'm choosing not
to wear the hijab part of this uh
bathing swimsuit because uh I don't wear
a gap I'm not going to worry dab and I
won't wake up I don't cover my hair
I stand in my power Nicole gets to the
pool and my mood was overjoyed to see
her in her bikini and he praised her for
being so strong you'll need your country
leave everybody
change your clothes change your mind
about saying this all like I I don't
know if I'm an institution I can do or
not I'm gonna need him to be more
consistent with that compassionate
energy they start to swim and for once
we see Nicole in my mood truly enjoying
one another without being passive
aggressive
no
although they are playing a bit rough
with each other
but it's cute I guess
the piece doesn't last long though
because emotions you bury will come to
the surface
she's always something I'm tired
okay apparently something set my mood
off while the cameras weren't rolling
Nicole told producers she's been trying
to please Mahmoud all day but when they
were changing out of their swimsuits he
started quote acting funny I asked him
what's wrong and he said something
passive aggressive to me like like you
like you care anyway I don't know why he
said it but I think it was totally
uncalled for
can you stop now
it seems like nothing it seems like what
he said was sort of like a nothing
but it had been building
and I I just I had enough
and I just snapped Nicole makes her way
to the street trying to get away from my
mood who keeps asking for clarification
on what he did
everything
exactly what I did just always picking
at me and I'm tired
I need to know what I did there just
leave me alone Nicole tries to walk off
again and that's when things escalate
I'm not going back to the street okay
what you where do you go now I don't
know
yeah
stop trying to control her Mahmoud leave
her alone let her walk she has a camera
with her so she's safe it's not like
she's not going to come home where else
is she gonna go every single second like
of every day that I've been here so far
it's just you picking at me like
anything yeah
good enough for you ever go find some
other
he said
I give up okay go
I don't understand like what's happening
I have a different wife if she visited
me no way no way wrong people just never
coming after they took a quick breath
Mahmoud goes and finds Nicole at a shop
and she still refuses to go home that's
when he tells her
she has to make a choice you have to
choose you want to go through Hunter
hello so if you want to look friends uh
I did I don't want to be anywhere near
you right now I'm not going to make any
decisions
you don't get to control me anymore I'm
tired of you okay so I will wait for
five minutes maybe not come with the
first I don't give up whatever you want
to do
my mood wakes those five minutes and
Nicole
show up not sure how I want to move
forward or if I can move forward or what
forward means I don't know right now
I mean until I met him I was single for
like 10 years
and I I don't answer to anybody so it's
really hard for all of a sudden this
like
he's nine years younger me or something
he thinks he can tell me what to do and
I let him I let him he's nine years
younger than her
I forget that
he says he didn't do anything to me
uh he hopes I find someone right for me
and if I didn't go with him in the Uber
then we were going to be divorced
[Music]
I just like don't have anything left in
me at the moment
my mood gets in an Uber and drives off
so I guess that means they're getting a
divorce
maybe not they've thrown that word
around a few times we'll see as I get
older the more I am realizing that the
most valuable thing I can have aside
from my health
is my peace
a romantic relationship is not like a
family member it's someone you choose to
be with and if my romantic relationship
isn't going to be enjoyable at least 90
percent of the time at least
I don't want it I'm not even sure if
Nicole has been over there for a week
yet and they've been constantly fighting
also why be in a relationship where you
feel like you have to dim down the parts
that you love about yourself and why I
have a partner who makes you feel as if
something is wrong with those parts that
you love hmm when it comes to these two
I hope they both eventually decide to
choose peace
all right well next week a major moment
is happening Isabelle's parents react to
Gabe telling them he is transgender
what would you like to know
historia
situations
[Music]
oh
I have a lot of questions all right 90
day fans fam make sure you stick with ET
because we are covering it all I will
see you next time
foreign